Joy Reed on MSNBC you hear what she
really thinks about Joe Biden's response
to the Middle East over the weekend
President Biden said he's ready to take
action if Congress is serious about
solving the Border
issue if that bill were the law today
I'd shut down the border right now and
fix it quickly and Congress needs to get
it done starting another
War still trying to kill the deal she's
expressing her real feelings about Joe
Biden right now this is a democ hack Joy
Reed is as damn hack as it gets she's
going here we go Joe Biden again
starting another effing War this guy
driving me crazy I want to pull my hair
out I hate this guy everyone everyone is
sick of Joe Biden
everybody your uncle your
co-workers the Republicans The
Independents even the big Libs on MSNBC
the guy is in trouble